I honestly can't remember what I was
supposed to say about how the dark is
manifest so let me give you a sort of a
broader and then you know the idea and
this is something a death sort of really
started to hint that that there was this
pre-big bang if you will only for battle
between God and the darkness I think
you're going to see that once we come to
spend time with the darkness that
there's a tremendous amount of
unfinished business here between
darkness and and the forces that put the
darkness away so and that's something
that is really sort of like treading new
ground in terms of we typically have
like the Bible to to use and twist and
play with and this is sort of fresh snow
for the show and that we're sort of like
making a lot of this like it's don't
make it over getting everybody but you
know what i mean so i think it will feel
fresh to the fans and but yet very
relatable and I can't really say why
right now but it's it's it's very
foreboding yet relatable and I think
this this big bad is going to have a
want unlike anything we've seen on the
show before and I think we're all pretty
excited about that so I don't mean to
the Duquette just I mean I'm horrible i
don't like to i'd rather i won't see it
on the screen yeah but the ones still be
interested to see it yeah
thank you
yes yeah that's a great question so so
one of those sort of like themes of the
season is it is you count he can't
outrun your past you know so I think by
a lot of devices faces from the past are
going to be appearing and in one form or
another we'll just say that and it's all
part of this ongoing sort of like goal
to figure out frankly what the darkness
is who the darkness is what the darkness
once and probably most importantly how
do we stop the darkness so yes they are
going to be visited by a number of folks
you'll recognize not many people know
and this includes New Zealand demon
steaming the scariest part is who was
around that the darkness is to some
people a bedtime story the Angels has
been alive for a good Julian year well
they weren't around when the Archangels
replace so they don't even know exactly
what to expect and I think that's part
of the fear that is sort of like seeping
into both heaven and hell because
there's a great unknown that is a cool
very big threat to everything
you